um hello Mr Roper thanks for joining us
you're not very happy are you
uh good morning Kate um no not entirely
um it's um it we think that it will
create
um a large impact on our existing
um local services our health services
um Security Services I.E the policing uh
we don't think that there's a support
network in place yet for these
individuals once uh once they
um are placed on the on the um
accommodation barge
so the minister a few moments ago said
that the people that are aren't being
housed on the budget will not be allowed
to leave the port so does that offer any
comfort to you
um I don't entirely believe it you know
from I must say we've had very little
consultation if any uh with the um with
the home office and the Portland Port
Authority but as we understand it it
isn't a prison and so although the the
port is a secure area that um that these
individuals will not be able to be
detained on that uh within that area and
that they will be allowed out
um on uh into the general areas of
Portland and also other areas of South
Dorset
well the minister says not is it being
economical with the actuality
um let's just say that we've we've heard
different a different story to what the
minister and spoke about this morning he
said that you didn't have any
consultation but the government telling
us this morning that they were working
closely with Portland uh port and that
they have said that the local Council
will be receiving three and a half
thousand pounds per migrant so is that
not true
um there's been as regards to Portland
Town Council there's been um there's
been added the voluntary sector which
importantly on on the island of Portland
there's been no consultation at all I
understand there's been some limited
consultation with Dorset Council which
are available at which are responsible
for the statutory services within with
it within Dorset obviously there's three
and a half thousand pounds per
um a person Seeker will be uh will be
welcome
whether um you know that sort of
trickles down the line to the uh to the
Town Council um we've yet to see as I
say there's been absolutely no
consultation
um with um uh the organizations on
Portland
are you going to launch a legal battle
uh we're not no we can't afford it um
and um apparently Dawson Council even
though they've have got a legal services
team
um have said that so there's no basis of
uh of um any legal action against this
um
um this action on of the barge and the
Asylum Seekers uh our local Mt Richard
MP Richard Drax has said that um he will
explore uh some sort of legal action but
um I I I I I just simply think it's a
done deal and so you know we're going to
have to accept it and work with it
he doesn't think so he says we want to
get this consigned to the Dustbin
although speaking to the minister this
morning it doesn't look as though that
is uh going to be the case so talk to me
in a bit more detail if you would please
Mr Robert but what sort of impact you
fear it could have on your local
community given that you don't believe
what The Minister's been saying
well um we've we've heard the hearsay
about the um about
um that the hotels and the localities
where the uh science have been housed
and the effect it detrimental effect uh
it has had on those
um localities
um obviously you know uh We've we've no
idea what what it will be like you know
um
um but
um the uh the the fact that um our sort
of Security Services you know on the
islands the the Port Authority have got
a very small police team the
um the we've only got one four times
police Constable with two pcsos uh on
the island and um when the
um when these individuals will be sort
of placed on the uh on the baharaji
accommodation barge uh it will be June
July which is just at the start of our
sort of busy tourist season here on
Portland
okay I mean you have had a bit of
previous with this haven't you I think
I'm right and saying I don't know if you
remember 20 years ago when the um when
the home office plan to turn the
ex-naval buildings where you are into
um a refugee camp what impact did that
have at the time
well I I've um I've I've seen uh sort of
pictures and on on social media and I
know that um uh that um the um uh the
residents of the island did yeah did
basically sort of uh protests or quite
strongly against the um uh the
conversion of the Hardy block you know
into uh into
um accommodation for uh Asylum Seekers
and you know that's culminated in
blocking the only Road on and off the
islands for a for a few uh a few minutes
um whether or not
um the uh you know that's a similar talk
of action will take place this time I'm
not I'm not sure oh were you talking
about civil unrest there Mr Mayor
these days you know I was pointing out
that's about 20 years ago it um there
was some civil unrest
will it be this time
I don't think so I think I think times
have changed the thing is that um that
um Portland is is a welcoming sort of
community and um I think what uh what
and the uh the words that um that I've
been hearing is that
um is that there's a lot of um sort of
sympathy for these for these people
um and um if they are going to be placed
on on the islands we will need to engage
uh in some way and uh and try and try
and make them welcome CSA will sort of
integrate with the um with the local
community as as much as they can you
know it will be difficult for them and
it will be difficult for us so you know
we we do have to engage with them okay
good to see you Mr Mayor thank you very
much indeed for joining us thank you